in this video we'll take a look at the
website for backbone j/s now everything
I do in this lesson you can do on your
own so if you're feeling especially
brave pause the video right now and
explore the site on your own and
remember that we're just looking for a
high level picture of backbone we're not
trying to get into the nitty-gritty this
page here backbone.js org is actually
the documentation for backbone now we're
going to look through this page and try
and get an idea of what exactly backbone
is and roughly how we can use it from a
high level perspective the first
paragraph bolds a couple words models
collections and views so we can infer
that the models are our data and
collections are collections of models in
our original model view octopus paradigm
we just had normal arrays in our model
view viewmodel paradigm with knockout we
had observable arrays in backbone
they're called collections and we also
have views with declarative event
handling will get an idea of what that
is in just a moment let's scroll down a
little bit and just skim through the
introduction section the first paragraph
says when working on a web application
that involves a lot of JavaScript one of
the first things you can do is to stop
tying your data to the Dom it's all too
easy to create JavaScript applications
that end up as tangled piles of jQuery
selectors and callbacks all trying
frantically to keep data in sync between
the HTML you I your JavaScript logic and
in some cases not our case the database
on the server so this sounds very
familiar this is what lesson one was
about writing a spaghetti code
application figuring out and you know
maybe it's not good enough the second
paragraph says with backbone you
represent your data as models which can
be created validated destroyed and save
to the server if you have a server now
here's the fun part whenever a UI action
causes an attribute of a model to change
the model triggers a change event all of
the views that display the model state
can be notified of that change so
they're able to respond accordingly
re-rendering themselves with new
information this also sounds familiar
this sounds exactly like what knockout
was doing keeping track of the way
things are connected so that way it can
selectively rerender different
parts of the view when the model changes
in a finished backbone app you don't
have to write the glue code or the
octopus code or at least a lot of it
that looks into the Dom to find the
element with a specific ID and update
the HTML manually instead when a model
changes the views update themselves on
their own now I'm going to stop here at
a very high level it's basically the
exact same things we've done before
keeping our concerns generally separated
from each other now if you look around
on the web you'll find all kinds of
shaky statements about what backbone is
it's not model view controller MVC if we
look on wikipedia will find that
backbone j/s it says is based on the
Model View presenter and the actor model
application design paradigm so we're not
going to talk about the second part but
if you read the rest of the Wikipedia
article at least as of now when I'm
recording this lesson it doesn't mention
MVP ever again now this guy named addy
Osmani who is a developer who really
understands this stuff and who wrote the
code we're going to be modifying wrote a
blog post about this understanding MVC
and MVP for JavaScript and backbone
developers this sounds like a wonderful
article for us unfortunately it's really
really long so I'm not going to go over
it right now with you but I would like
to point out one particular area of it
about halfway down he says in this
respect contrary to what might be
mentioned in the official documentation
or in blog posts backbone is neither a
truly MVC MVP nor mvvm framework it's in
fact better to consider it a member of
the MV asterisk family which approaches
architecture in its own way there's
nothing wrong with this but it's
important to distinguish between
classical MVC and MV asterisk should you
be relying on advice from classical
literature on the former to help with
the latter in other words what he's
really saying is backbone doesn't
exactly follow the MVC model view
controller or Model View presenter or
model view viewmodel paradigms backbone
kinda does things a little bit
differently so now we know a couple
things definitions like MVC and MVP and
MV
em are not the be-all end-all we also
know that MV asterisk means patterns
that do it differently from our
traditional patterns and to make things
stranger if you read a little bit more
between the lines you'll find that
backbone is pretty agnostic about how
you organize the communication between
the different parts of your application
so what we're going to do is we're going
to rely on the code that we're editing
to dictate how things are done and we're
going to check out the documentation
when we need help or when things don't
work so it may seem strange to say but
in order to make a few changes to a
particular project sometimes you don't
have to understand it fully it's
important that we remember we're looking
for a general organizational picture
here not a super detailed one we aren't
going to learn backbone j/s really
really well all of this documentation is
here to help us but we're not going to
understand what every single piece does
if we had to learn a library 100% before
we could make any changes that would be
impractical and unsustainable let's take
a step back from all of this and talk to
Jean of our front-end developers about
strategies that we can use to start
adding to a project without the code
that we add sticking out like a sore
thumb